alors que la france attaque sa deuxième
quinzaine de confinement les pronostics
sont ouverts pour tenter de savoir
durant combien de temps cet enfermement
imposé sera utile pour éviter la
propagation du virus
et si le premier ministre a prolongé les
mesures jusqu'au 15 avril prochain il a
déjà annoncé que cela n'est qu'un début
nous nous installons dans une crise qui
va durer dans une situation sanitaire
qui ne va pas s'améliorer rapidement
mais alors combien de temps allons nous
rester assigné à résidence difficile à
dire tant cette crise sanitaire est
inédite et semble imprévisible mais
alors que certains artistes programme
déjà leur concert en mai et en juin et
que d'autres organisent leurs vacances
spécialiste et membre du gouvernement ne
sont pas tous aussi optimiste alors
qu'il parlait d'un retour sur les bancs
de l'école le 4 mai prochain jean michel
blanquer r le ministre de l'éducation
prédit aujourd'hui qu'un autre scénario
est possible selon virgin martin politis
sociologue il ne faut pas espérer un
retour à la normale avant six mois
d'après un article scientifique et l'a
relayé sur les réseaux sociaux le
confinement actuelle est loin de tout
régler l'article précise également que
le scénario d'un vaccin miracle pourrait
prendre du temps des prévisions qui ne
sont pas très optimistes alors se
dirige-t-on réellement vers un
confinement de six mois
[Musique]
alors est-ce qu'un complément de six
mois est-ce que c'est possible
professeur anne est ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que le cyclo
confinement c'est pas la recette miracle
je crois que les gens ne comprennent pas
très bien le confinement ça sert à
ralentir la transmission du virus a fait
ralentir le virus et ça va pas éliminer
le virus
bien sûr logiquement une épidémie elle
s'arrête lorsque toute la population et
féminisé ou d'une raie 60% de la
profession une musique ou alors la
population est vaccinée comme pour la
variole c'est ça qu'ils arrêtent
l'épidémie
quiconque cherche avec le confinement
c'est ralentir le but russe pourquoi
pour éviter des vagues de mortalité donc
on retrouve éviter c'est que tous ces
patients arrivent très rare en même
temps timmer donc on va ralentir ça
c'est à dire qu'il restera toujours un
bruit de fond parce que la compilation
elle sera toujours naïf de ce virus et
donc il y aura toujours une joie en
chine il ya toujours des intérêts
infestations par les par les pays à
risque des voyageurs qui reviennent vers
la chine
donc on aura toujours un bruit trop de
cette infection le confinement sert
simplement à éviter ces vagues de
passants qu'on ne peut pas absorber
alors confinement on l'a vu en chine
deux à trois mois
ça a servi à bien aplatir la courbe de
la progression de la maladie et à
maîtriser les choses mais toutes les
régions de la chine
en dehors de wuhan elles sont vierges ce
virus elles sont à la merci d'une à re
démarrage de l'épidémie de vaincre avait
alors émis qu'avec le vaccin musique
toute la population cynisme paolo levi
six mois est-ce que c'est possible ou
pas apple ou non ne s'est pas lassé
c'est magnifique parce que je suis sur
le toit de chez moi il est je pense 20
heures et il ya toute la ville qui
entrent à leur premier relais le
personnel a dit m
magnifique bas bravo bon curry c'est
vrai que c'est incroyable
et bravo bien qu'on vous laissera net et
toutes vos équipes et toutes les équipes
bien sûr les belles images en direct
bah merci paulo nous fait revivre ces
années bien cyril hanouna ici
il est à dire la symbolique en mode lent
mais vas-y mais j'adorerais tu nous a
fait mal c'est bien nous avoir fait
vivre ça paulo nogueira qui priorise et
en direct non t'as raison mon chéri tu
aurais pris ça fait très chaîne d'info
non la question sur les six mois écoutez
les gars et il ya une seule solution
plus on est discipliné dans le
confinement plus tôt ce truc se
terminera moi franchement j'ai trop
envie d'aller à la mer cpt donc je reste
à la maison je bouge pas je m'en fous
maintenant je vais trouver mon épicier
du coin jeux je descends avec une petite
ficelle montanier lui même et la bouffe
je remonte comme on faisait à naples il
y à ajuster y encore quelques temps et
je reste ici sur le toit donc je rejoins
complètement le propre c'est pas ça qui
est qui contribuera à à tuer le virus
mais en tout cas on va le bon fil ce que
le virage en faveur vers nous ils
fabriquent des visio vous vous dites six
mois c'est possible ou pas moi je dis
qu'on selon moi j'étais en ligne hier
soir avec rome avec avec le gouverneur
en fait l'équipe du gouverneur de la
province du latium et en fait eux ils
ont annoncé jusqu'au 15 avril mais en
même temps ils ont commencé à préparer
la population de toute façon à l'idée
que les enfants retourneront pas à
l'école avant septembre
alors ouais donc c'est à dire qu'en fait
on s'installe en fait dans la durée en
fait mais il ya un point important qu'il
faut savoir c'est que le confinement en
fait comme l'a du professeur c'est pas
une mesure médicale
aucunement c'est une mesure qui va
aplatir une cause ce qui est de mes
dires médical et qu'on ne fait pas
actuellement qui va poser un gros
problème c'est les tests vous ne pourrez
vaincre le virus que si vous testez
tester tester si les mots de l' oms et
c'est bien ce qui m'inquiète temps il
faut préparer une stratégie de sortie de
confinement que ce soit un mois ou à
quatre mois il va falloir en sortir de
ce confinement et qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour en sortir il faut tester et isoler
les porteurs sains c'est ça le véritable
enjeu mais donc vous dites que c'est
possible j'aimerais avoir l'avis d'yves
cochet yves cochet donc en cinq minutes
de l'écologie vous pensez que c'est
possible si moi ou vous pensez
est ce que vous pensez il coachait qu'on
va pouvoir sortir de ce coronavirus où
vous pensez que ça va être impossible
qu'on s'en sortira jamais
on va en sortir au point de vue de la
crise sanitaire mais cela paraît par
exemple que dans dans six mois ou dans
un an au moment de l'hiver 2020 2021
il n'y ait pas de nouveau une épidémie
de ducros navires us deux celui là où
d'un mutant de celui là et d'autre part
sur quoi il faut s'attendre et on le
voit déjà maintenant c'est à un choc et
même un crash économique considérable
on est déjà patiemment à -35 % par
rapport aux cours normal des choses du
point de vue de la mondialisation et moi
je pense que à l'été prochain et encore
plus à l'automne et en sera encore plus
bas dans la marche de l'économie et il y
aura même peut-être des ruptures dans
certaines chaînes d'approvisionnement je
pense toujours à la chaîne
d'approvisionnement alimentaire
parce que si vous n'avez pas d'aliment
les gens se révoltent passera le pillage
le chaos
et en plus c'est à rome actuellement on
va plutôt basculer vers l'amérique que
me foyer ils ont d'infection majeur et
l'amérique est évidemment implique a une
influence dans le monde entier et en
plus ce sont des gens qui sont armés
donc s'il ya un chaos social voire des
guerres civiles dans certaines villes
dans certains états des états unis
je ne donne pas cher de l'ensemble du
monde